à baume les dames il était encore là
déterminés à faire entendre leur voix à
l'entrée de la commune sur la
départementale 6 183 à quelques
encablures aussi de l'accès au
supermarché et les femmes sont là en
première ligne souvent en famille comme
marie qui a connu les luttes de 68 et sa
fille nathalie unis pour la même cause
nos enfants nos petits-enfants et puis
que la vie c'est un petit peu meilleure
ce que toujours payé travail moi j'ai
travaillé toute ma vie j'ai en retraite
et donc on me pique encore sur ma
retraite je suis régleur sur presse à
commande numérique et je travaille de
nuit pour 1300 euros de salaire voilà et
les taxe qu'on a
donc nous nous ronge la vie quoi on se
bat aussi bien pour avoir une vie un peu
meilleure que pour maryvonne aussi la
coupe est pleine
je suis une vache à lait comme tous les
français où beaucoup de ses plus grands
et puis en a ras-le-bol des taxes des
taxes des taxes mart et abs et
maintenant tout augmente elle aussi
avait prévu une manifestation en famille
avec sa fille et sa petite fille aline
et anna tous unis les enfants nés et
grands-parents les animaux voilà tous
contre voilà tout c'est eux hausses de
taxes est tous ces problèmes qu'on a en
france nous voilà on est solidaires tous
ensemble
je pense qu'on fera plus fort qu'à 68 à
12h30 elles ont décroché pour prendre un
petit encas grâce aux dons que lee gilet
jaune ont reçu un geste qui leur a mis
du baume au coeur
faut continuer jusqu'à 17 heures